che è la registrazione c'è che la carne
sono contente ripasserò allora molti di
voi mi hanno chiesto di fare questa roba
perché siccome gli avevo spiegato che i
ragni e insetti nella vita reale mi
provocano tachicardia roba del genere
perché io soffro di questa roba
avevo anche detto che attraverso lo
schermo io non non soffro l'aracnofobia
e queste cose
sì però mi fa comunque molto schifo
vedere un ragno insetti attraverso lo
scambio a fare questa challenge dove
guardi gli insetti che vi assicuro che
preme guarda io preferirei mille volte
guardare il dubbio non suoni cup che sta
roba
non sapete cosa manca bene quindi se
dobbiamo farci stare action facciamo st
[ __ ] reaction ast o come si chiama
insetti pg gli insetti più grandi del
mondo
roba del genere e vabbè 321 pax dei
besnier state partners
[Musica]
apro il passato zio cazzo e questo
beckham torna a casa a guardare chi
cazzo è questo
questo non mi spiega quest'uomo quando
lo pagano i danni miliardi di euro
qui diamo un miliardo di euro a
quest'uomo per favore per cortesia ma
perché non lo farei niente per ragazzi
no non puoi certo vinto nel cazzo stai
mangia ma che schifo
frate corona non c'era una scatola di
cereali e dei trans che ancora peggio
chi ce la sta roba dura un'ora e 33 cioè
questa fatto un'ora e 33 di documentari
sugli insetti giganti ma quest'uomo non
è donald trump
quando ti hanno pagato zio che li do io
i soldi per farvi capire il mio grandi
sofferenza nel nord est veli valuto da 1
a 10 dal vivo non potrei mai fare non
potrei avvicina la faccia ma un bisogno
non sappiamo è gesù cristo sa che
schifosa che temerario è quest'uomo ci
si appassiona torna di dare la [ __ ]
perché questo è the rock un cazzo di
confronto che se questo è l'uomo e
l'uomo sette e mezzo mi fa schifo adesso
però non è anche troppo perché sembra
voglia quindi questo ancora ancora
mangiato dimitrova asti cosa si cela una
matrona ceschi collega 8 questo era 8 o
terreni che chissà se c'è io quello che
solo in casa porca [ __ ] che schifo
che schifo come fanno esistere vero
che poi comunque per fast e sceglie
hanno preso un ragno vero e l'hanno
messo in proporzione quindi sarà la fa
schifo uguale però va bene boing show è
show grazie di questo primo piano di
merda che erano proprio bisogno grazie
per gentilissimo acquistare mai così
vicino a una merda del genere invece a
telefonarmi anche chi non è d obbligo
per immagini ad e trovare una roma così
come non vi date fuoco dai componenti
non ho capito bene cosa ha detto mi ha
parlato di sesso tra anni che
probabilmente quello che stiamo vedendo
che era interessante io non vedevo l'ora
di vedere questa cosa c'è davide mattine
mi svegliavo di ciò che ha fatto il
sesso i ragni cazzola stesso solisti
sono proprio contento di averlo visto
grazie eni bucks king ed eni ma ce ne
bulbi ai box che sono poi riempite di
soldi quest'uomo subite di fila e tutto
quello che vuole
si giunge così ma come cazzo si fa a
essere così ma puoi ma non esiste una
persona
non può esistere veramente non puoi
riciclo che è bello che siamo ritornate
vedere le tue orecchie enormi e non
quella merda di prima
volevi polemiche forse cita la felicità
dei consigli palle corte dovrà salvarsi
su iran c porca vacca lay down the
grosso con lo schifo è una nissan
qashqai suoi se non in regola è finita
finita a volte sui rami è finita
abbiamo finito ragazzi la parte sui rami
e mi sento sollevato a c.so una questa
clinico pronto questo è bello sembrò
cavatappi la gara questa roba della
madonna
naz un secolo di primera 10 beautiful e
sfocia sting e per justin aveva per
limonare gli altri insetti così a è
quindi una questione di limone spararci
hanno bisogno di cornificata vicenda che
tanto ci hanno già dal giorno figata
bello il sesso visto la madonna quello e
l'uomo ma neanche gli esseri umani
riesca la fa ste robe fichissimo perché
non ho mai visto queste cose su youporn
e sarebbe un ottimo implemento perché
non è implementano cielo già duro orca
vacca che bello che bello molto ma molto
meglio guardare all'uomo lardoso molto
meglio anche loro fanno il sesso è bello
ma questa è mia suocera farle paura di
morire perché qualcuno cosa potenza al
bistrò il temerario alla morte che cazzo
metti standosi cappella di sottofondo fa
veramente vomitare
sai che si fa vedere un ragno e poi mi
metti la medaglia se lo dia tutto
sibello spacca garua read it è un
puntiglio buon dio buon dio black widows
ma come fa più bello la finiamo sabbath
e finiranno di a durare ancora tanto
grazie madonna immagini che così può
trovarsi
nella roma del non viene ignorato se la
trovo nel mio garage che cazzo ma io sì
ostrava nel mio garage che cammina
friends un fucile ma e sparo appena una
loro bravo bravissimo e ho finito
un'ora e mezza di documentare non lo
sono guardato ovviamente tutto scappato
le parti più più belle per concludere
ragazzi e in bellezza di andare a
guardare una cosa che io da piccolo mi
sono ritrovato davanti ed è stato un
trauma perché avevo tipo medio dieci
anni forse anche un po meno ai tempi
andava sulla tv il guinness un record
roy i primi guinness record non quelli
con gerry scotti
i primi che andavano inondarono proprio
in inglese
c'era tra quelli la tipa che si teneva
un ragno in bocca un veicolo per quale
[ __ ] motivo è facile bolle si devono
ragni bocche faceva le bolle voglio
andare lì e se me lo ricordo che è
rimasto impresso poi andare a ripescare
quel pezzo e concludere con quello made
io cosa ho visto cos'è schifo facebook
ma che che cosa grande cazzo è no
ragazzi non era questa la cosa nuovi no
ma questo non ci avrei mai vederlo beh
certo tomb janvier dall'australia non
poteva essere altro che dall'australia
sto cristiana questo si sveglia la
mattina e gli abiti addosso perché sono
in australia grazie al camp nou raga non
lasciava ciò questo giuro su dio non c'è
mi fa veramente schifo era questo forse
era un amico è sicuro che non è tipo da
non era nativa rom tipo ciao fratello ti
avrà la tuscia con i soldi e regate
spero che questa sala ragni bocca e fare
bolle ai problemi più belle scoppiate
con una tarantola in bocca a 119 bolle
in 30 secondi io il più tali da latte
vaccino anche una di bolla con una
tarantola anche solo un chilometro di
vista
ad imboccare questa situazione qui per
me è l'inferno in terra non c'è niente
di peggio forse solo la freddo dai
ragazzi abbiamo visti insieme sacco di
cose bellissime e divertenti guarda
quando ho avviato sto video vero proprio
contento non ti mi chiedono falli ma
qual è la parte più divertente del tuo
lavoro io rispondo sempre registrare i
video perché quando gioco io mi diverto
ecco in questo caso mi divertirò un
sacco anche a montarlo questo video però
mi sono divertito un sacco anche adesso
che i ragazzi spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto spero che abbiate imparato
molte cose sui danni su come fanno il
sesso su come non me ne frega un cazzo
di come fanno gli stessi ragni questa è
stata reaction delle reaction non farò
mai più una reaction così ma ve ne siano
100 ragazzi con il momento mi piace
anche vari social che come video con una
descrizione saluti di sereni ci vediamo
se un video dai ragazzi
[Musica]